Okay,
we are back live.
Good morning folks.
We have a few things to do today. Um,
as I kind of said yesterday,
really not doing like a huge amount of
stuff this.
We're kind of just doing post-release
stuff. We're doing a few posts on uh
Twitter and everywhere else. Making sure
that people actually see our release.
We're fixing up some things that I
haven't had time to fix for people who
are uh involved with and using Puffer
Lib, let's say. trying to fix up some
things with the meta environment. I told
Stone I'd do some robotic stuff. Just
know a few little things here and there.
Um,
and then, you know, sometime in the next
couple weeks, we're going to really
start on the new stuff with drones and
more industry side.
They're having some meetings with
various bases off the uh off the stream
looking for problems we can solve with
uh RL going forward.
Pop out the chat real quick and then
I'll this over to the green view
and I think what we're going to do on
I got a meeting in like an hour, no two
hours.
So that's good. Um,
what we're going to do in the meantime,
we're going to see if we can figure out
this meta environment and what's going
on with it.
Can I figure out why it's this slow?
Actually,
maybe I can just figure out
Yeah, let's do like test
at uh
Okay. So, does this work?
If so, we can run profiler on it.
there way we can get profiling into C
from Python
when it's like an external thing that we
don't have control over
or am I going to have to set up like uh
level profiling?
Tricky with the way that they've
developed this specific environment.
So, pretty much what I'm trying to do
here is I'm just trying to figure out
why this end is so slow. Um, so I can at
least have some idea of how to set up
efficient experiments on it.
It might just be that it's just slow
overall, but I'm hoping that they're
going to be like some combination of
settings that are at least bearable. Uh,
we're going to eventually have to
rewrite some sections, I think, of it or
reoptimize some sections, at least help
the authors do that. But in the
meantime, just looking for something
quick.
Oh, okay. So, we actually do get
This is way too big, though.
See what this does.
Oops. All right. One second. Apparently,
I have countertops being installed right
now. I'll be right back.
I'll have to monitor that, but
otherwise good to do a little bit of
work for a
Okay.
So from this
we can see the problem
and I checked
Probably the replay riders probably
filling up my whole disc space as well.
And now we have
most of the time is coming from samples.
Now, this is probably going to tell us a
very different story, right?
Yeah, very different story.
That's 680k.
And that's actually as about as fast as
we should expect it to go anyways,
right? Yeah. Let's just let that train.
And actually, we'll we'll log that
on Neptune.
And I'll tag it
Good.
Go check on the counters.
I have had a uh a piece of plywood for
the kitchen counter for the last couple
of months. This uh building is not fully
finished, so that's nice.
All right. What's going on here? This
This thing does not appear to be
training like at all, right?
let me see what we put in the config for
this.
Actually,
maybe we should just try to run this
thing.
So, this is finishing eval. And once
this is done with Eval, we're going to
actually now finally, and this is why
it's taken me so long to actually even
do anything with this end. We didn't
have the replay viewer working. At least
now we'll be able to see what it is this
policy is doing and whether it makes any
sense, whether the environment is a
problem or what.
That ought to give us a couple replays.
Give it a minute to run.
The hope is that today we'll actually be
able to get some
at least some sort of reasonable policy.
Got you two articles. What you think we
should post first?
Terraform.
Uh I just did
two technical articles.
Don't think
we can try. Let's see if we try this
one.
See,
Okay, let let me read it and then we'll
think on title.
this image could be the uh you need an
image for the uh the header of it. This
could be it.
This is hilarious.
Let's see that. So, that's the main
thing that we got to look at is the
title and the uh
and the image.
Yeah, this basically just needs to be
rewarded. The the thing is you're trying
to say gamify your problem so that
reinforcement learning can solve it.
Like
Yeah, I don't I don't think that's a
particularly good header image.
Presumably
you have this in X article format as
well, right?
52. I mean, honestly, this thing
this thing here is pretty close.
You can literally just paste this into
uh like a Google a Google draw and like
add white space on either side if it
doesn't fit and it'll be fine.
There's really nothing even about G.
This is like an enticing concept, but
the article really isn't about
Maybe we do the other one today actually
cuz I'm looking at how basic this one is
now. This one will do well, but I don't
know if it matches the release week
stuff as well.
This is like reinforcement learning
basics or something, right?
But like how to game like honestly you
could make a separate article on like
how to gify a problem for RL. This is
not really what this is. Like that's
like a really effective thing and
there's actually quite a bit of
technical depth on that. Like if you
think about it, right, that's like a big
chunk of what I did with neural MMO 3.
There like a ton of ways you could set
that problem up, most of which don't
work.
This is cool. Let me let me read through
this and see if this is a better fit.
Uh the content is fine for the first
one. It's just I don't know if it fits
like staging in the release Take
Hang on. They're uh putting the
countertop in and I guess cutting it or
something.
Okay, I think we're good. We'll see.
I guess they're like grinding it so it
fits something.
What's this doc article? We're uh I'm
This is a Spencer wrote an article. I'm
just looking it over. We're doing like
one article per day for uh the 3.0
release. So, we just have tons of
articles and we're just releasing one
till per day until we run out.
probably excluding the weekend.
Spencer, it would be good to mention
that um right here that like you know
you often you're targeting performance
marks that can be uh
should mention that the uh the target
speed can be like 10,000x what you would
expect for a normal game, right?
Like that we can actually like you can
continue to train faster like by making
it like a th000 to 10,000x faster than a
normal game at least.
More than 10,000 ups.
So, like in the original game, right,
like a human's only going to need to
climb a couple blocks.
like you only need to simulate a couple
blocks per second and then it's like 60
frames or whatever. But what we do is we
do like a million like movements per
second and you can actually train a
neural net that fast. Um, I so I guess
it's worth mentioning like just how fast
these things are compared to like what
how fast a normal game would On.
What's this line supposed to be,
Spencer?
I think this is there's like a missing
sentence here, right? Like it's
compressed so that you uh you have lower
CPU toGPU transfer, right?
Yeah, I just I missed it because I was
distracted. It's fine. Yeah, this is
fine. Spencer.
Yeah, this is cool. Can we get a Can we
get a header image where the puffer is
not like looking away from the screen?
Other than that, I think this is uh
good. Now, I don't know if the title
fits in um you got to make sure that
like the full title shows up on the
post.
You might have to tweak that.
I mean, you could just use the second
part to be honest if it doesn't fit.
Like training AI to beat an unreasonably
hard puzzle game
is pretty good.
So, yeah, do that. Put it into an
article nicely and let me know so I can
repost it.
want to read Terra while you're at it. I
can look.
So, this is just an this is just Mars.
Doesn't show the end.
this is a really good quote.
I honestly I think that after you post
this, like in a couple days or
something, you should just tweet this as
a standalone.
This is really good.
This is a good article, Spencer. I think
these two are these two are quite nice.
I don't think you post these back to
back. I think you do you can pick one
and then do a different one. So either
of these is good for today. Um
and then like we'll space them, right?
So like ideally we it's we probably have
two weeks worth of articles really. So
we'll space it so that there's different
you know that there's variety. It's not
just like all the M's and then all the
this and all the that. I find when I
post like one M today, one M tomorrow,
next day like it doesn't get much
traction.
I don't know if the thumbnail just
having a random screenshot of Mars.
This is an art like you got to know that
this is Okay. So, here's one thing to
know about your uh about articles,
Spencer. This is something useful. So,
you got to think of the preview. So,
it'll show you the image, the title, and
then the first couple sentences of the
post. That's all it will have.
So that's all people see before they
actually decide if they want to read the
article. So they'll see like maybe this
much like this much stuff. So I think
like the content of the article is fine.
Do a little bit of thinking about how to
do this and then you know either this or
tower climb whatever. Um and I will
repost those as well. Like a decent a
decent quote tweet.
Okay.
Oh no, I forgot I had this running.
Uh yeah, we generated a bunch of
garbage. Holy
going to factory tour right now. We'll
post after. Solid.
All right,
let me see if we can actually
make this thing work now.
okay cool. So,
I mean, we can immediately see why this
doesn't work, right?
Number of agents will be one
agent.
and
96.
So, the expected reward here, let me
think what the expected reward is. It
should be quite high, right?
Am I rewarding this thing for
just for getting rewarded for hearts?
But, I mean, it should pretty much just
be able to do
You should be able to get tons of these.
if I remembered to track this.
Didn't. That's okay.
We'll just watch it.
This should definitely be able to go
above one.
It seems like there is specifically
only getting one is a thing.
It's a very small map. It should have no
problem with this task. So, I suspect
that we're going to load up the policy
and we're going to see something weird.
That's like the most likely.
It is also somewhat annoying to me that
we can only do this like 50 million
steps.
This thing is minimum of 10 times Well,
is it 10 times too slow? It's really
only two or three times too slow to
think of it.
You should not be getting bottlenecked
by the environment.
This article's done pretty well. 40k
views on something this technical.
Oh, this is awesome.
Yeah, this artificial life type work is
really cool.
There's definitely something about
I always think it's suspicious when like
rewards are at numbers like that.
Exactly one and it's never gone above
one.
Oh,
and corrected.
Went slightly above one.
I think it should just be able to do way
way more than that though. We'll see
from the uh the replay, I guess.
It also didn't take very long. 50
million steps is considered very very
quick. Just that the code is slow. So I
mean this should have been like a one
minute experiment or whatever.
5 minutes for 50 million has not been a
thing since uh buffer 10.
I would like to know why this thing gets
stuck on eBel for so long, but whatever.
Not quite
have something
Dominant.
What does that even mean?
there there.
Now,
okay, this is what we wanted. This is
the simplest possible environment.
I don't know why their play button
doesn't work, but
Oh, it just literally chills there.
Let me see.
It doesn't do anything. It literally
just chills there.
I don't think that that's better.
like
that design doesn't exist
like that design doesn't exist really in nature and I don't think it's
really in nature and I don't think it's
very effective.
I do hope we'll see like severalfold
increased capacity for cardio and
strength though and intelligence.
I mean, let me tell you, the other thing
that would just be great is if we
actually could fix freaking muscular
injuries quickly because I got a bad
rotator right now. I cannot bench the
bar before I hurt this rotator a few
weeks ago. Could bench 210 for 10 quite
easily.
And I mention bar
ridiculous.
Now these all have zero have zero
initial items right
Stay away from benching.
Uh, actually I didn't hurt it on a bench
press. I heard it on an I heard it on a
uh dumbbell shoulder press. I've never
had a major injury from benching.
Okay, so this should basically just go
straight up here.
Yeah, I I mean somebody it was a pretty
I was being careful. Somebody distracted
me. It was like it was a whole thing.
But I think it's only like a it should
be a pretty minor injury. Should be like
it should at least be peeled enough in a
few more weeks.
won't need surgery or anything.
I mean, we can see this thing is
correct, right? Like this.
It's like getting tons of ore because
obviously it should be able to get tons
of ore because it's really freaking
easy.
Now we don't give it any reward for
getting ore
and we give it
now we give it only reward for the
second stage product.
Okay. Very very small bit of reward
there.
But I don't know if that's going to be
enough for it to latch on. We'll see.
It technically should be possible with
um new advantage filtering stuff.
Okay.
Interesting that this thing is like
this is definitely better than random,
but it's not like um
it's not just like learning it with any
real speed.
Let me try different hypers.
I think that the hyper pram are really
jank on this.
We just like
What happens if I just do this?
Okay. Does this make a difference?
Looks like it does. We'll see if it's
stable.
Oh, yeah. Hypers. Just bad hypers.
Quite slow. This thing better not be
dumping replays.
I'm dumping replays. Just slow.
All right.
Now we will see whether it can get um
get any reward off of this.
probably just a combination of many like
small changes just making it very
suboptimal for learning.
Now, it is interesting here. I don't
think that they're getting
any Yeah, they can't do this randomly at
all.
They've kind of created a little bit of
a degenerate loop here with the reward
structure, right?
like by rewarding for intermediate
products.
No idea what you're doing, but admire
your discipline. I mean, I can explain
what I'm doing in a pretty simple way
here. Like
a lot of these problems we work on are
either games or they look like games,
right? Even the industry ones we
essentially gify. So we're basically
we're just thinking about how we can get
this AI to learn to play a game uh by
thinking about the structure of the
problem and like
kind of the way in which we're rewarding
the agent for doing different things in
the game.
What I'm kind of doing here is like
it's sort of like how you learn math in
school. Uh to solve this problem, you
have to go to this mine. You have to
collect three ore and then you have to
take them over here to get a battery.
And then three batteries make a heart.
So I'm kind of figuring out how I tell
the agent to like that it needs to do
these three things in a row implicitly.
I'll talk more once the vacuuming is
done in here.
I don't know if it's coming through on
the mic, but it probably is.
No noise now. Okay, I guess my filter is
really good because I can barely hear
myself talking.
let me try something.
If they only have 10 items,
I don't think they can get rid of items.
Can you get rid of items in this?
I don't think you can.
the filter.
It better be. This is a very nice audio
setup.
Okay. So, my idea here is if we reward
them a little bit for ore, a little bit
for batteries, and a little bit for
hearts, what I would expect to happen
naively is it's just going to like spam
ore and get this forever. Um, but if we
kept the inventory to be pretty small,
like it's going to see that its
inventory is full and it's going to have
to get rid of the ore and like the
resources somehow, and the only place to
get rid of it is going to be in these
other converters.
So, we'll try that.
this is not going to tell us anything on
its own until we actually see the uh
graph here.
The maximum score it can get from or
alone
2.5 I believe.
Okay. So once it's above 2.5
because it has 10 slots and it gets 0.25
rewards each.
So it means it has to be it has to
basically be freeing up its inventory.
Let's see if I'm correct. Yes. You see
this? It's starting to make batteries
This is what we want to see, which when
we run this, I expect it's just going to
be running between all three converters.
Don't pay attention to these graphs as
much.
Uh, I actually don't think that these
are correct. I think that these are just
logging wrong.
Oh, yeah. I
Let's see if we're doing numbers on
LinkedIn.
and it's starting to peak. It's also
expected, right? Because you can't get
infinite rewards when you don't have
infinite time.
Soon as this eval, we'll see how well
this does. And uh well, I at least have
something to
this a minute to eval.
Hopefully, this is at least a decent
starter policy.
Anything great.
This should be decent enough starter
policy. Uh then we will basically just
be able to take this thing, run it on
the full maps, and see if anything
happens.
I wish that this thing would actually
this buttons would work.
Well, I guess we'll have to do it this
way.
Get a full inventory of
stuff from the mine.
Then it's going to go find
the generator.
Who made that? This is uh Meta with two
T's.
You can find their GitHub,
not Facebook.
Okay. So then they do this conversion.
right. So, this now that this works, the
question is, can we scale it up
or do we want to do the cool downs
first?
Maybe we want to do the pull downs
first.
Pull down.
What did we say that they put
many things for there?
Two generators, 10 mines, six agents.
Okay, so we'll do like two here.
Basically, we just see whether this does
anything.
This will make it substantially harder
to learn.
Basically, just the agent can't see the
waiting animation.
Oh, cuz I left the replay if you were on
like a dummy.
If this works,
then possibly the full map work. See,
are they actually doing this for um
their configs?
Okay. So, the only problem here is I
don't know
the scale of anything.
this is way lower
and uh we don't it's not getting any
hearts yet, which is a problem.
Oh, no. It is. It's just It's at one.
That's actually good.
And realistically, I think that the max
you can get is like two, isn't it?
Cuz you need nine. Hang on. You need
nine ores,
which you actually have to take the time
to collect.
I guess if you go between two mines, you
should be able to get two hearts.
You know what? I wonder if it was I
wonder if this was a straightup logging
change.
This could have been a straightup
logging change. No,
maybe not cuz there were 10 mines.
I'm trying to figure out like cuz we had
a version of this that worked before,
but like I basically never saw it. I
just trained them a policy and sent it
to them and they were like, "Oh yeah,
that's really good.
This is expected because again the cool
down times are totally different.
These metrics are
these metrics are definitely reported
wrong.
Definitely
wonder how they're being reported.
We'll look at that in the meantime while
this finishes training.
This a lib or you made that?
Which visualization?
Oh, this one. No, this is this is the
meta, guys.
they they build everything like the
exact opposite of the way that I do. So,
uh we have our visualizations on um on
puffer.ai.
Like for instance, this is one of the
ones.
This is probably the NF that I built
that I'm most proud of.
See,
hang on.
by mistake.
Okay. Uh you cannot run this while also
running training at the same time.
You link it anywhere?
Discord.
Okay, I'm going to have to read through
this. This is gigantic
template.
What do you mean just a template? I
mean, it's huge, right?
This is several times longer than all of
the current docs put together, right?
says is part of this AI generated
because there's stuff that does not make
sense in here. Like we don't have a
puffer libmodels.policy
and then there's like they're like
random characters in the middle of this
from like is this SAM script?
I think it's like some SAM script
characters.
What do you mean by a template? Hey
Brad, how's it going? What What do you
mean by a template? Because like a
template is like something that you copy
and then you edit it for your own
environment, right? Like we have one of
those.
But this is not what a template is,
right?
Sample sample template.
Okay. So I guess you just mean it's like
something sort of like this. Okay.
So I mean you basically what you want is
you want you want like a from scratch
tutorial like assuming you don't know
any RLS like at all. Okay.
Yeah,
that can be arranged
You have to realize that like literally
before puffer live, this wasn't a field
where that was a a reasonable thing to
even do cuz like it was so much harder
to even do anything that like a I'm a
beginner. I don't know RL. How do I like
make cool new stuff? It's like, well,
you just don't. Um, now though, yes, you
actually can do that in Puffer Lib, and
our docs just have not caught up to
that, which is fair.
That's not a Puffer Lib guide anymore,
though. That's like a RL basics, which
Yeah, we can do something for that. It's
like RL basics with Puffer Lib.
It's not Puffer Lib Basics. It's like
kind of RL Basics. Yeah.
I have a meeting that's technically at
1, but the guy told me he's probably
going to be a bit late.
What I'm probably going to do is I'm
going to message him like, "Hey, let me
know when you're
around
ask people start from scratch
again like this was the type of thing
where this start basically this started
off as a toolkit for PhDs in
reinforcement learning right and then we
made it simpler because we made the
library way faster and way simpler right
then we brought it down to like okay
this is a toolkit for like AI people who
are trying to get into RL, right? Like
people with like research experience in
other areas. Maybe you have like a
masters or a PhD in another area and
you're trying to do RL. And then it got
to the point where we literally have
brand new programmers that can actually
do stuff with it now and the docs
haven't caught up to that. So that is a
fair point.
Like I'm going to have to figure out the
format in which to present this. Like
you understand why I can't just like put
this as the documentation page, right?
Cuz like if I put this as the as the
documentation page, then like
experienced RL people are going to be
like, what the hell is this just like a
tutorial library for beginners? Like
where do I find the information I
actually need? But I need to kind of do
both and I they need to be in separate
places.
A bachelor student learning puffer li
from their first year of college.
Yeah. So, this is the thing like you can
actually do that now as a bachelor
student in your first year of college.
Uh, I tried to do RL as a bachelor
student in my first year of college with
the tools that were available back then
and it was impossible.
Like it doesn't matter if you're a
genius, just couldn't do anything at
all.
Um, so times have changed and now
actually we can do stuff. And
admittedly, like we've actually had
undergrads contributing really awesome
stuff now. So do you want to have docs
for that? I just have to figure out how
to present it, right? Because like if
you present the docs like the main docs
pages like this is like for ultra
beginners, then you lose the experienced
people that you also care about. So I
have to figure out how to put it
separately. I might do it as like a blog
post more than anything, right?
That might be better to just have like,
you know, um
like like quick start RL with puffer lib
for complete beginners or something.
Yeah, there will have to be like two
sections or something. Now, like putting
two sections, I'll play with the format.
Basically, I hear you and like, okay, I
can do something to have like a complete
beginner guide that covers the
information that you put in here, but I
have to decide on the format, right?
That would be great. Yeah. Okay. So,
this is something that people want.
This is something that people want. I
just have to figure out the form to
deliver it.
In the meantime, until I've done that,
I literally stream all day. So, if you
have questions, you ask them here.
This read me on squared example. this
code doesn't actually run is the thing,
right? Like
it's generally not a good idea to
include code examples for code that
actually doesn't run, right? Like you
don't do like a code walkthrough when
the code doesn't actually work.
But we'll have to tweak some stuff on it
at the very least.
Yeah.
Okay. So, this is this one. Let's see if
we
Welcome, humble fool. What is this end
of about? It's resource conversion. You
have to get three ores from here and
then put the three ores in the
generator. That makes a battery. And
then three batteries go to the altar and
makes a heart.
I mean, this agent has learned this task
pretty well perfectly.
Percy Leon,
what tweet have you linked? Percy
That's a good thing to do.
I don't know. I don't know how they
actually do this. If it's like from
scratch, but actually it's PyTorch, then
that's kind of silly. But like, yes,
language models from scratch, it's good.
Honestly, the best resource on that, I
don't know about this course, the best
resource on language models from scratch
is Carpathy's GPT2 speedrun,
like his like GPT2 original code,
actually before all the crazy speedrun
stuff is really good. Read the replies.
Okay, for some reason those didn't show
up. Hang on.
I would either do it like you can use
linear right you can use basic layers
but obviously don't no transformer or
attention or whatever
um or I would go lower level
brighten
Yeah, this is still pretty high level.
Honestly,
this is a good thing to have. It's still
pretty high level. I mean, that's is a
good course. Like, I would have taken
this if I were uh the student there.
That's like good.
How did you define rewards for Pokemon
Red? There's a blog post.
You see, there's a blog post. It covers
everything.
You can also at that guy in uh Discord.
I'd buy a course if you offered one. I'm
not in the business of selling you
courses. All my educational content is
free. I sell um I sell my services to
companies who are trying to like solve a
hard RL problem uh in their business.
All the other stuff's free, including
the code. Be right back. I'm going to
use the restroom real quick and then I
got to figure out where this guy is for
my meeting. Uh but he's probably going
to be late, so I probably have a little
bit longer here.
Brad, if you want to like learn this
stuff, literally the best way is to just
get jump into the puffer discord and
like start building some environments.
You learn and at the same time you
actually help advance all the research
that we're doing. Let me go figure out
where this guy is for me.
So, uh, the plan for folks, uh, I have a
meeting. I don't know when the guy is
going to be here. He said he'd be late,
like fairly late. So, um, at some point
I'll just hop out and hang on, let me
message him and then I will be live back
afterwards.
really appreciate stuff you've open
source. Thank you.
I mean, honestly, at this point, like
most of the stuff in Puffer Lib, like
the majority of the code, at least the
end code is written by contributors,
right? Um,
and some of them come out like really
well
and like in a way you wouldn't even
expect. Go look at Tetris on the
website. It's absolutely mesmerizing.
Systems capable of analogy and
reasoning. That's going to be more
language stuff I would think than
you might be more interested in language
stuff. It's harder to do language though
because like frankly you can't really do
any research.
You can't really do much meaningful
research in language modeling space at
the moment because everything's just so
big and expensive. RL is one of the few
places in AI where you can really just
make a huge difference without it
needing a ton of resources.
How do you define if an agent has
learned a concept? Well, I mean right
here, look uh it's not just this map. it
like any permutation of where these
obstacles go.
This agent has learned that it needs to
get three resources from the mine, put
three resources into there, wait for
them to convert, and then it's going to
have to take them out and it puts them
into the alter to get a heart.
It very clearly understands that because
this is randomized during training. So,
these obstacles can be anywhere and
it'll do the same thing.
LMS don't do analogy and reasoning. They
definitely do. They definitely do.
They're they're fuzzy and they make
weird errors in ways that humans don't.
So it's like it's not a onetoone like
exactly like humans, but they definitely
do follow stuff like that. You can just
ask it like you know you can like ask it
to complete an analogy and it'll do it.
Abstract the concept to a new
environment. It can. It's just a matter
of extent and a matter of error classes,
right? Like for instance, it's never
seen this specific environment during
training. Like I guarantee you it's
never seen this exact placement of all
the obstacles.
So this is generalizing in some sense.
It hasn't seen this exact environment.
They say, well, what happens if I only
put one mine in or what if I make the
map bigger? There are classes to
generalization, right?
Let me just make sure I don't miss this
guy because I don't know if he'll check
his Twitter DMs.
Uh I don't think that
I think you might be surprised with
that. I
like the way that we do it is going to
make
it's going to make errors that people
don't, but it's also definitely going to
get things right that the average person
won't, right?
Like if you go like try to come up with
like the most novel analogy you possibly
can. Ask a bunch of people and then ask
the LLM and see.
Yeah, I think like a lot of the LLMs
can't reason stuff is kind of just
silly. Um, but like on equally silly is,
oh, LLMs are just super human. They
already they solve everything. They're
great. We should just do everything with
LLMs. Like that doesn't work either.
They're kind of useless for programming
for me, for most of the stuff that I do.
Um,
and they're useless for a lot of other
things as well. So like, yeah.
Okay, I got to run to this meeting. Um,
thanks for tuning in folks. I will be
back right after this.
Uh, if you want to check out all our
stuff, it's all at puffer.ai.
Start the repo to help me out for free.
Take a look at our latest release.
Puffer 3 is here. It's all open source.
Follow me on X for more content. And
we're posting all sorts of cool RL
articles.